talking with Chris Hardwick tell us
about this sir um it's basically just a
chat show on AMC cuz I do talking dead
for most of the year and they said you
know if you if the other Sundays that
you're not doing talking dead if you had
a chat show what would it be and I said
I'll just I would just talk to people
for an hour so that's all we do so
Donald Glover is on this season and
Chris Pratt and Karen Gillan and Ethan
Hawke and Seth Rogen and it's just like
a nice just a nice group of people and
that's it it's just kind of like the
podcast but a chat show that's really
cool and tell us quickly I know people
are obsessed with Walking Dead through
these rumors out there that yeah I just
dropped another one that Andrew Lincoln
lauren cohan might be might be leaving
the show do do do you get any insight or
dope on that kind of stuff I really
don't ask you all they do they do and
they really think that I know and I
don't I don't have an inside track on
any of it cuz I don't want anything
spoiled so they don't tell me that stuff
but people really they honestly really I
used to think talking dead people like
why you got to have a show that talks
about another show and I'm like first I
don't like your tone second of all
second of all it's like therapy for
Walking Dead things happen on the show
you get upset and my dumb face comes on
I'm like everything's okay you know
right that person is alive in real life
it's not a documentary and so we need a
version of that that comes after this
show the show talking Coco yeah where
you sort where maybe you'd be kind
enough to do one where you just say like
okay that wasn't great but we're all
still okay
just really quickly when things happen
on the show or like went like if you
hear these rumors that are going around
which I don't know if they're true or
not but if when you hear these rumors
and people get really upset then they
yell at me and I realize I'm not therapy
for walking dead I'm walking dead
customer service yes that is different
where people like I know you didn't do
this but you represent the company so
double you and you're like ah and I just
want to tell a very quick special story
about how I know I was reaffirmed that I
was with my soulmate you know my wife
one night I was getting particularly
beaten down on on some Walking Dead web
sites people just really angry and my
wife is falling asleep I'm in bed it's
dark the dim glow of the computer laptop
is glistening off my ashen horrified
face and my wife rolls over she goes
what's going on I'm like people being
mean to me on the internet and she goes
what are they saying and I go well
Juggalo nuts 4:20 said that I'm a [ __ ]
salad and I don't know if that's like a
bed of lettuce with poop on it or like a
bunch of poops mixed together I don't
even know why I don't even know what's
happening anymore
and I'll never forget this moment she
goes well don't read that I go it's my
job she very sweetly rolls over just
rubs the hair around my ear and just as
sweet as can be he goes well maybe you
should stop being such a little [ __ ]
you're not the only husband to get that
little talk
you